hallo YouTube Chancellor my friends this
is grunge in here welcome to the seventh
part of the dirty chess tricks I am
continuing my coverage of tricky
reparata against the classical response
to the King's pawn opening that is let's
say after E 4 E Phi Knight to f3 Knight
to c6 Bishop to c4 and here we are
looking at the move Knight to f6 that is
two Knights defense here I propose that
you should play the move d4 and we come
to a conclusion that the best move here
from the black perspective is the move
he captures d4 afterwards
why should castle on the Kings side and
the last lecture I have covered the move
Bishop to c5 so if you haven't watched
that I have highlighted here in the
annotations
in this lecture we are going to cover
the move Knight captures efore
the morphe attack start with the move
rook to even the main move here is defy
but in case if you are wondering what
you should do after the move file then
here is the answer
why should continue with the move Bishop
to g5 and after Bishop to e7 just
capture that bishop and after Queen
captures Bishop white can capture this
Depot and there are so many threads over
here white is threatening to capture an
f5 there is a main threat is f3 and top
of everything black cannot castle on the
King side so all in all it's a wonderful
position for white and that is the
reason why at this point the main move
is defy after the move defy why it has
this amazing piece sacrifice that is
Bishop captures d5 so more or less black
has to forcefully accept this sacrifice
and after this White has this move that
is Knight to c3
for those of you who are slipping let me
remind you that black cannot capture
this night because after D capture c3
black will simply lost the Queen so that
means black Queen has to move somewhere
now the amount of games I have played I
found out that mainly three moves has
been tried by the black wing there are
other moves but they are very rare and
that's why I'm not including in this
lecture the first more I want to
consider is the move Queen to h5 which
looks very logical that if the white
moves the knight they play can swap up
the Queen here white will continue with
the move Knight captures efore and you
can already see that there is a
discovered attack looming which will lap
the black Queen so black has to block
the e-file there are two ways black can
block the file the first is Bishop to e7
afterwards why should continue with the
move Bishop to g5
now if your opponent is not familiar
with this position he may be blundered
moves such as f6 because white can
simply take this pawn and black cannot
recapture this phone because the Queen
will drop so the castle looks the first
priority but castle is a blunder move
and the correct answer from the white
perspective is the move Knight to g3 so
we have the double hit to the bishop and
not only that what is threatening to
take the Queen so very obvious is when
the Queen moves white will be a piece up
now instead of Bishop to e7 black can
block the file with the move Bishop to
e6 blacks planning is very simple black
wants to castle on the Queen side so
accordingly Y needs to stop that non yr
the move Bishop to g5 now here the three
moves has been tried first let me show
you the aggressive move by the black
that is Bishop to b4 so it has a idea of
attacking the roof but here white can
sacrifice a pawn why the move c3 after
DC and DC black Bishop has to move to
the a5 square and afterwards White will
continue with the move Queen to d2
here two moves has been tried both leads
to instant disaster for black in one
game my opponent played the move Bishop
to b6 but to his horror he find out that
night to g3 and the black queen is a
goner if the Queen goes to the g4 then
the rook to e4 will trap the baby and if
the Queen goes to the g6 then Knight to
h4 will do the same
so it's very obvious that at this point
the main move is the castle but after
the castle still black loses because of
the move Knight to g3 once again the
queen strap so Queen has to go to the g6
square and when white played the move
Knight to h4 black has this idea that is
Bishop capture c3 so counter-attacking
the White Queen and if the Queen
captures Bishop then why its own Bishop
will drop so here white will continue to
move Queen to e3
so black needs to follow the Queen with
the move Bishop to d4 afterwards now
there is a sequence of capturing happen
so here I capture the Queen my opponent
recaptured the Queen and now I capture
the rook and after the sequence Bishop
captures and Knight captures Bishop pawn
captures Knight and rook captures after
the whole transaction White is a clear
exchange up the second ugly move is f6
but you can already see there is
something wrong in this movement the way
to exploit is Knight captures f6 forking
the king and a queen so black has to
accept this then afterwards White will
capture this bishop with a check
the most obvious response is skiing to
d7 afterwards White has this amazing
shot that is rope capture c6 and the
funny part is black cannot capture
either of the white piece for example if
King captures rook then the very simple
light captures d4 will nab the black
Queen so that is not possible and if the
King goes to the c8 square then rook
captures f6 and white has save all the
pieces and emerge with a clear piece and
upon up
last but not least if black plays the
move at 6:00 then white bishop has this
amazing posting that is on f6 square
fortunately for white black cannot
capture this because there is a knight
folk accordingly two moves has been
tried in the first game my opponent
played the move Bishop to e7 but after
this I just captured this bishop and
after black recapture I captured the D
pawn which leads to the endgame which is
a very good for white in this game my
opponent continued with the move Queen
captures cui and after rook captures
there's a threat of capturing the bishop
and isolate the pawn so my opponent drop
the bishop back to the d7 and now I once
again hit the bishop and the befall why
the move Knight to c5 so my opponent
again save the pawn why the move Bishop
to c8 but after night to b5 there is a
no escape
because King cannot come to the da
square that means C pawn is dropping
there is a second alternative for the
black here that is to play the move
Queen to a5 which has an idea to
capturing the bishop now but here white
can sacrifice the whole piece why the
move Knight captures d4 let's see what
happens if black accept this so G
captures f6 and very obviously is Knight
captures f6 with a check now King cannot
go to the d8 square because of the
discover check and black loss the Queen
so the King has to come up afterwards I
give you a few seconds can you find an
amazing decoying move which will finish
up the black
okay the move is before and it turns out
that this is amazingly strong whoo let's
see the consequences of different black
moves if Queen captures b4 then the very
simple is Knight to d5 and black lose
the Queen if Knight captures b4 then
white can capture this bishop and the
base move over here is King captures f6
afterwards black king is in making net
why the move Queen to d4 check of course
King has to go to the g6 square
afterwards white will simply snap up the
rope
and the following continuation which
will illustrate how dangerous white
attack is my opponent continued with the
move Knight captures see - so [ __ ] -
looks but here white first of all give
this check so the only move left is King
to f5 because if the King goes to the G
fire then droop - if I will left the
Queen
so King F is forced afterwards white can
give this check which will gain the
Black Knight and if black becomes greedy
and go for the night capturing then
black king will be mated after rook to
e4 the only move left is King to g5
afterwards where has this silent killer
move Queen captures f7 and there is a
mate in three maximum
last but not least one of my opponent
right here
Queen to g5 but after this once again
white can capture this bishop and in
this game
my opponent captured with a pawn which
leads to the instant finishing after
Queen to d7 check the only move left is
King captures f6 afterwards the black
King dance will continue with the move
rook captures e6 let me show you the
rest of the moves very very quickly the
King fall on the floor after Queen to h3
so those are some of the amazing tricks
exist in Queen to h5 line let me show
you some good tricks in Queen - a fine
line after Queen to a5 why should
continue with the move Knight captures
efore and once again we are threatening
a discover chat so black needs to block
the check once again there are two moves
first we are looking at Bishop to e7
after Bishop to e7 White will continue
with the move Bishop to g5 and no need
to mention the move f6 that leads to a
disaster
so in this game my opponent tried the
move Bishop to e6 afterwards I continue
with the move Bishop captures a 7 and
after Knight captures a 7 I just grab
the depot
so which force black to castle on the
Kings side afterwards night to see if I
create a great difficulty for black
because black cannot move the bishop
and in the game my opponent decided to
counter-attack with the move rook to d8
but he missed this move that is Knight
captures b7 and white emerge with a
superior position
so that's why the main move over here is
Bishop to e6 afterwards there are two
moves you can try but before looking at
them there is a one nasty trap that
white need to aware that white cannot
capture the d4 pawn because I can simply
capture this night and white cannot be
captured because the two point even is
hanging so don't fall for this one
instead of this I am suggesting that you
can try twos the first move is Bishop to
d2 and after the logical move Queen to
defy white can set up a nasty trap why
the move Bishop to g5
now the most usual response from the
black perspective is the move Bishop to
b4 attacking the white rook and planning
to castle on the Kings side but this can
be made why the move c3 and at first
sight it looks like black can simply
capture this pawn but in fact it's
turned out as a blunder now I can play a
super-short that is Knight to f6 check
back
so black lost the Queen how let me show
you so very obvious response is G
captures f6 afterwards Y can snap up the
screen and that Bishop is spent so black
cannot recapture
the same story can be said if your
opponent play moves such as Bishop to c5
because now White has this second good
move that is c4 once again D captures c3
is not possible because of the night
check and black loses the Queen once
again
and if the Queen goes to the f5 square
then the very obvious is night to h4 and
once again black lost the Queen if Queen
to g4 then f3 and g4 nap the Queen and
if the Queen goes to the e5 square then
f4 trap the Queen forever now at this
position instead of Bishop d2 white can
also try the mainline stuff that is
night e to g5 which has a merit of
hitting the bishop
if black try to defend the bishop why
the move Queen to defy then once again
White has this amazing shot that is
Knight captures f7 King captures f7 is
force and afterwards Knight to g5 will
not only regain the piece but King has
been misplaced
so after night e 2g file the main movies
to castle on the queenside
afterwards white can regain the pawn
back and here the main move is Bishop to
d6 what should continue with the
harassing the black rook why the move
Bishop to g5 and if rook to e8 then
Queen to e2 is exceptionally strong so
that's why the main move over here is
rook to f8 which has a cunning idea to
capturing the night and then capturing
the bishop but here I can set another
good trap wire the move Queen tweet
allowing rook to f3
because now White has this finishing
shot
rook to b8 check
if root captures then the Queen captures
and blacking will be mated
and if black block the check with the
noise then the very simplest rook
captures rook and two of the black
pieces are hanging
the last move I want to consider is
Queen to d8 afterwards white should take
this night with the check and once again
the main movies Bishop to e7 afterwards
white can capture this deep one
now there are two moves has been tried
in the first black captured the night
why should capture with the rook and now
if the black blogs the file with the
move Bishop to d6 then he will lose the
pawn after Bishop to f4 so the following
sequence is like this and you can
already see not only white is emerged
with a clear pawn up but black PCs are
not ideally placed in the second
continuation if black block the chat
with the Bishop to d7 he run into the
bigger problem because now white can
still continue with the move Bishop to
f4 and black cannot castle on the King
side so in one game my opponent tried
this c6 and after Knight to e4 Queen to
c8 and Bishop to d6 he found that he
doesn't have anything except C Phi
here I continue with the move rook to d5
and then he played the move Bishop to e6
which will allow me to enter into the
endgame which is exceptionally good for
white so you can see this white emerge
with a clear two points off and a far
better position the second move is
castling on the Kings side once again
white can play the move Bishop to f4 and
black is having a huge difficulty
defending the c7 so for example if
Knight captures d4 then the rook
captures and the same problem on the c7
occurs and instead of that if black
plays the move Bishop to d7 then white
has this amazing shot that is bishop
capture c7 Queen has to recapture and
afterwards the following sequence will
emerge white with a clear pawn up and a
better position so you can see yourself
attacking Queen and a bishop
so Queen has to drop back now white will
first of all capture this Knight which
has a merit of hitting the Queen
so bishop has to recapture and now white
knight will capture this bishop with the
check and when the King moves Knight
will capture this bishop
and you can already see after this whole
transaction not only white emerge with a
clear upon up but black bonds are
shattered on the queenside
so I hope you enjoy this wonderful mafia
track you have the plenty of
opportunities to trick your opponent
along the different ways of the Queen
moves I wish you best of luck for trying
in your own game well thank you for
watching this video and I will meet you
in my next lecture that is Italian
gambit against Bishop to c5 bye